pas que je pleure
valérie t'aime très fort et maintenant
on est réuni pour toute la vie
salut c'est juliette imagine que tu vis
toute ta vie en pensant que tu as enfin
unique et un jour tu découvres que tu as
un frère ou une soeur ou mama par an
dont ignorait totalement existence ça
ressemble à une histoire qui n'existe
que dans les films mais récemment j'ai
lancé une messagerie pour voir si ça
touchait beaucoup de monde est en fait
vous êtes assez nombreux à avoir vécu ça
habituellement il est découvert qu'une
marée
mon frère m'a tuer a pris 13 14 ans que
le mec qui m'a élevé ce n'est pas mon
père ça change tout dans toute ma vie
des deux très compliqué derrière
préoccupant de l'identité est tout j'ai
appris il ya quelques tannique mon grand
père n'était pas mon vrai grand père et
ma grand-mère avait caché pendant des
années la vraie identité du père de ma
maman en fait j'ai lancé cette
messagerie parce qu'il ya quelques
semaines j'ai reçu un message sur un
stade qui m'a beaucoup touché
bonjour je vous contacte car j'ai passé
toute mon enfance dans l'ignorance
totale je ne connaissais personne de ma
famille aujourd'hui je viens de
retrouver ma soeur si cela vous
intéresse on peut se parler évidemment
que ça m'a intéressé j'avais super envie
de films l'histoire de ces deux soeurs
qui ne se connaissent pas et assister à
leur toute première rencontre du coup
j'ai répondu à sandrine et aujourd'hui
je vais vous raconter son histoire
après un casting
36 naya est ma li na s'il n'est s'ils
sont là l'insee si elle est là
ophélie si elle est là noémie ciel est
là sandrine organise une fête pour fêter
l'anniversaire de sa fille elle a fait
une grande liste d'invités mais elle
espère surtout la présence d'une invitée
super importante sa grande soeur qu'elle
n'a encore jamais rencontré en fait le
truc ça qu'elle ne sait pas quand ça
sort va venir c'est le stress non plus
très fier il faut point de faire pour
prendre les choses comme elles viennent
c'est un bon moment à passer c'est bien
pour toi c'était pour pour tout le monde
pour tes enfants
donc là je t'explique maier
aut ouais
tu vas laisser ton lit naya
et toi tu as le choix soit tu dors avec
papa et maman dans la chambre dans un
lit parapluie ou soit tu dors avec les
cousines
j'en étais sûre
et du coup de tête à valérie est ce que
tu as mal et vitus et qui sait alors ce
qui t'as ta valley c'est la soeur deux
mamans voilà sandrine a 26 ans et elle
est née dans une famille de parents
toxicomanes à ses six mois elle est
placée en famille d'accueil car ses
parents ne savent pas s'occuper de sa
mère décède d'une overdose peu de temps
après son placement
en famille d'accueil donc j'étais chez
monsieur et madame chacornac
ça se passait très très bien
quand tu en famille d'accueil ta famille
d'accueil a tout à fait le droit de te
remettre dans une autre famille
d'accueil quand ils partent en vacances
que moi la chose que j'ai eu c'est que
je partais en vacances avec ma famille
d'accueil partout où il allait j'ai
suivi son père meurt quand à la mi-temps
et sandrine devient orpheline du coup sa
famille d'accueil décide de l'adopter
l avant son avis se marient et a deux
enfants
tout se passe bien jusqu'au moment où
elle découvre qu'elle a une maladie
génétique du coup elle décide d'aller
retrouver son dossier auprès des
services sociaux donc on est arrivé donc
à la dass j'arrive dans le bureau blanc
il y avait qu un bureau plan
sandrine assieds-toi et de l'amdi
vous êtes au courant de quoi de votre
passé dix vaches au courant que j'ai un
frère n'hésite pas au courant vous avez
une soeur qui recherchent depuis 26 ans
là j'étais
vidé il n'y a plus rien qui sorte et je
dis pas non je vous courant de rien du
tout grosse info sandrine découvre que
son père a eu un enfant avec une autre
femme et que cette fille du coup ça sort
à 17 ans de plus qu'elle ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que dans ce dossier des
services sociaux il y a aussi des
dizaines de lettres que sa soeur lui a
écrit au fil des années et que sandrine
n'a jamais reçu et m'a donné le dossier
est la rentrée les lettres que me sera
écrite
et j'en revenais pas j'ai essayé de
l'appeler sur numéro qui est écrit sur
la lettre bien évidemment depuis ce
temps là les ça n'existait plus le
numéro il ferait au téléphone j'ai
regardé sur facebook
mais ce qui m'a sauvé c'est que son
prénom est avec un y valérie est qu'à y
n'y en a pas beaucoup
et j'ai vu sa photo il me cousin
n'existait pas elle il y en a peut-être
beaucoup sinon c'est elle
le 18 février
et marqué un bon soir je vous envoie un
message bien je suis là alors choses de
ma soeur et j'ai été chercher le doute y
est on est on vous dit que c'est terry
et quand vous avez reçu ce message tu
cesses indique comment ça s'est passé
comment j
ou
c'est magique m'en étais gens dormez
plus quoi ce jeu si au bout de vingt six
ans retrouvé ma soeur pour moi c'était
impossible je retrouverai jamais coup au
décès de son père valéry apprend qu'elle
a une soeur à ce moment là elle a 25 ans
et a déjà trois enfants
pendant des années elle cherche à entrer
en contact avec sa soeur d'abord via des
lettres et ensuite on la cherche en sur
les réseaux sociaux mais comme sandrine
ne porte plus long sans faire impossible
à retrouver le seul visage que les avc
d'une photo une photo quand j'ai eu
l'idée l'appartement de n'ont pas suffi
de l'appartement
donc ça que j'ai vu qu'elle est mal
existé mais les lits avaient tout quoi
non je m'étais mis d'accord avec les
services sociaux la dass tout pompé en
fait on puisse créer des liens se
rencontrer de temps en temps enfin il
m'expliquer comme j'ai été sa soeur et
tous que je pouvais pas les enlever
comme ça du jour au lendemain et en fait
eh ben j'ai jamais eu de suite et quand
j'ai demandé à voir des contacts on a en
a jamais voulu me devais de contact je
n'avais pas droit de pointe de contact
avec elle a strictement rien point
j'aimais bien aller sa maman
je m'attends à wail
étant alors très chaud
voilà
ça c'est aussi du coup comment vous avez
appris que vous avez une tente par maman
a un amant tata
ils ont faim que je pense maman
les qualifications pour avoir
dit qu elle était sûre d'elle et après
ils ont fait un mélange vision concevoir
la première fois la conversion à l'été
tout gêné bastiacci moi j'ai un prêt
vous
les deux soeurs c'est pas tous les jours
depuis plusieurs mois mais ne se sont
encore jamais rencontrés sandrine c'est
que valérie va venir lui rendre visite à
un moment en juin mais ne sait pas
exactement quand valérie décide de
partir avec sa famille quelques jours
avant la fête pour lui faire la surprise
pour filmer leur trajet du sud jusqu'en
bretagne je leur passe une petite caméra
que tu vois qu'il ya petite lumière
rouge à c'est que j'ai envie exactement
et si tu veux te filmer toi tu dois
juste tournée prendra exactement couple
est maintenant tu pendant sa lune ou
mais du coup tu peux te regardes et tu
vois ce que je veux dire
c'est parti pour la bretagne
les go
[Musique]
les enfants vous êtes décharger ses
beaux fruits le mari on est là
haut des cols aller
ça va non
quant à l'arrivée c'est un ensemble
garder cette histoire
tic tac tic on les a mis
[Musique]
là dimanche on rigole on rigole on fait
la fête à rire ah mais moi si mon coeur
qui bat lâché en fait ce que ma fille
est en jeu ma soeur
ça fait ça fait dix ans qu'on est
ensemble on discute de ses racines de
tous assuré au final du coup le fait
d'avoir quelque chose de concret
maintenant avec des vraies personnes
avec des vrais visages de mètres
derrière choix et pas juste des noms et
des familles s'en fout c'est chouette et
puis va même pour une fois c'est une
belle famille que j'avais pas et qui du
coup si jamais comme ça
après voilà à moi d'apprendre d'avoir
une seule peine dans ce que ces héroïnes
soeur
[Musique]
les enfants dorment
4h20 petit arrêt la route l interminable
on n'en peut plus on est au bout de
notre vie
[Musique]
chapeau mais là où tu vas pas la plage
tu vas l'école c'est
et voilà nous arrivons sur la femme
tac
je dis au revoir
un son
[Musique]
de tout temps breslau na li
sava oui vous fait
jusqu'à une heure hier soir auquel
quoi faire
[Musique]
ok petite pause dans l'histoire mais je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais avec
le micro cravate on entend le battement
hyper rapide burger
[Musique]
ça va pas
tu fais un stationnement effectivement
le petit
bain c'est sûr ça c'est sûr la mer gens
sérieux alors le p
voilà vaches
nous aimerions une femme quand je vous
ai connus quand j'ai su que vous étés
l'argent
et tous les jours je regarde pas les
médias sont aussi assez bon
j'y vais pas parler mon passé je vais en
parler comme ça mais pour moi j'étais
tout seul puis j'ai avancé tout ça le
quoi tu vois que tu veux tellement
habité à
6,7 hors éléments a
été notamment pour demander mon accord
ce moment son départ tous ses papiers
s'en moque ou un gsm social pour ça je
pense que je veux à l'ennemi c'est
comment savoir à la caunette ou super
nes et à étape par étape en fuite
après un trou tu peux dire tu es
tranquille dans ta tête malgré ses 26
ans foncé voilà j'ai toujours été bien
avec eux ils m'ont les sorties de la
meilleure de sens où je ne serai plus là
honnêtement
après c'est fait c'est fait on pourra
pas revenir en arrière sur la corse et
voilà est ce que ça te rend en colère de
savoir que l'on a empêché de voir
quelqu'un qui était louis oui je suis
beaucoup en colère parce que c'est du
mensonge enfin quand on a grandi dans le
mensonge
je trouve c'est du grand n'importe quoi
le fait qu'on nous dit pas qu'on nous
cache les choses
plus on dit jeunes mieux c'est parce
qu'après ça fait beaucoup de dégâts bon
je vais quand même laisser tranquille
pendant le reste de l'après-midi
lendemain pour qu'elles puissent se
retrouver en paix après 26 ans mais
ensuite j'ai rejoindre pour les
célébrations de l'anniversaire
[Musique]
seles et sinon un vent glacial
depuis 18 ans valérie rue cherche des
réponses à ces questions et c'est
surtout en rencontrant le père adoptif
de sandrine qu'elle espère en obtenir
bon ça frise vérifier à la nuque et
ensuite on à vendre là
directeur
la demande y comme est
notable est ce que vous voulez
oui
c'est surtout celles investies au
départ il a commis
non non j'ai besoin france avait demandé
au cabinet classe et là on l'a rencontré
on m'a dit non tu es aucun droit avec
deux compagnons ils me répondent à une
série que je n'en voyais qu'il fallait
je pense le seul souci est qu'on aille
pas exsangue il sait qu'en fait on a on
a beau poser quelques questions à ce
qu'elle essaie de poser la question c
est qu on n'a pas de réponse
et qu'on a peut-être jamais une tête à
la suite de dossiers temps à recevoir la
rosée dossier mais qui est bon qui
traîne malheureusement c'est un peu ça
aussi que je vais faire comprendre dans
le reportage c'est que c'est pas tout
facile sinon une route qui va être c'est
sa droite jusqu'à la wii maintenant
c'est ça mais maintenant il va falloir
apprendre à se reconstruire
bruel passer ça c'est notre objectif
une fois que tout sera fait tout sera
fini que moi je me sentirai prête que ma
soeur se sentira prête on enlève tout le
passé on pourra pas rattraper le temps
perdu ça c'est sûr mais après je veux
qu'on me fiche la paix avec ce passé là
c'est une nouvelle vie qui commence
et sinon je vais dire quelque chose
aussi et je la vois pas maman il ya une
phrase que tu m'as dit il ya un mois que
j'ai retenue tu m'as dit je suis très
contente que tu es retrouver ta famille
parce que le jour où tu devais partir je
sais que tu ne seras pas seul et ça
merci beaucoup et valérie vous aussi te
dire que je t'aime très fort et que
maintenant on est vraiment peur outre la
vie
je viens 110 n'ont pas toutes les
réponses sur leur histoire mais en tout
cas aujourd'hui elle ne se quittent plus
cet été sandrine ira avec sa famille
routes rues et valérie dans le sud pour
des vacances et elles sont déjà en train
de faire des préparations pour les plans
de noël des histoires comme celle ci je
les trouve assez haut et ça me fait
toujours plaisir de vous rencontrer et
de raconter vos histoires sandrine elle
m'a trouvée via justement ma demande
dans la fin de bisous de vidéos donc
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un message sur
instagram si vous devez un sujet que
vous voulez que je traite si vous voulez
voir d'autres vidéos comme celle ci
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
brut et 11 ans la prochaine fois
maintenant